[Music]
resilient and vibrant societies are
built from the grassroots up
the european union
has developed its project on the support
for democracy peace and common values
and today
this mission must continue
this is why we are making
1.55 billion available for the next
seven years for projects supporting
european grassroots organizations and
the respect of fundamental rights and
values
this is the biggest budget the european
union has ever had for this work
it will substantially contribute to
reinforcing a union of equality rule of
law rise and values and democracy
over the next seven years we will
provide funding to support civil society
organizations in their work on promoting
these values
these organizations play such a crucial
role in keeping the rule of law intact
we want to see projects that fight
intolerance racism xenophobia
discrimination
hate speech and hate crime we want to
see projects that promote democratic
participation
and empower people to actively
contribute in building our democratic
societies we want to support those who
care about europe's future with funding
today i warmly encourage organizations
who are ready to promote our au common
values to apply for the citizens
equality rise and values funding program
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you